determina el dominio y rango de la
función f x igual a 3 x al cuadrado más
6 x menos 2 muy bien vamos a empezar con
el dominio el dominio de una función es
el conjunto de números que podemos meter
a la función y obtener un resultado
válido en este caso pues podemos poner
cualquier valor de x verdad cualquier
número lo podemos elevar al cuadrado
multiplicarlo por 3 sumarle 6 veces el
número y restarle 2 así que en este caso
el dominio el dominio es muy sencillo el
dominio
es todos los números reales todos los
números números reales reales en
realidad hay otros números los
imaginarios y los complejos que también
podrían estar en el dominio pero como no
hemos platicado mucho de ellos nada más
nos vamos a quedar con esta idea con la
idea de que el dominio es todos los
números reales es decir los positivos
los negativos este las fracciones y
otros cuantos más que están por ahí vale
bueno pasemos ahora al rango al rango de
la función el rango de una función es
todos los valores que la función alcanza
es decir si ponemos ya igual a efe de x
entonces el rango es el conjunto de
todos los posibles valores que puede
tener y como le vamos a hacer para
determinar el rango en este caso pues
vamos a hacer la gráfica de la función y
eso nos debería a pues nos debería
ayudar a determinar el rango vale cuál
va a ser el plan el plan va a ser
graficar esto de acá que si te das
cuenta es algo cuadrática entonces es
una parábola es una parábola que se abre
hacia arriba
o bien es una parábola que abre hacia
abajo
y bueno una vez que tengamos la gráfica
podemos identificar el vértice de
nuestra parábola y si conocemos el
vértice pues todos los valores que
podemos alcanzar son aquellos que están
por arriba del vértice y los que no son
los que están por abajo vale misma idea
si están si estuviéramos en este caso
los valores que podemos alcanzar son los
de abajo y los que no son los de arriba
como aquí tenemos un 3 un coeficiente
principal positivo entonces estamos en
este caso de acá nuestra parábola está
abierta hacia arriba o sea que se ve
como una
ok entonces vamos a hacer la gráfica y
vamos a ver dónde está el vértice
generalidad podríamos utilizar la
formulita del vértice que nos dice que
está en menos b / 2a aquí nos quedaría
menos 6 entre 6 o sea el vértice estaría
en menos 1 pero déjame hacer una tabla
para ver qué también nos podemos apoyar
en eso entonces aquí va a estar la tabla
de valores de x y df de x vale
entonces xy efe de x
ok entonces vamos a poner aquí menos 2
vamos a ver cuánto nos da la función en
menos 2 cómo le hacemos tenemos que
hacer 3 x menos 2 al cuadrado o sea 3
por 4 para eso tenemos que restarle
porque va a quedar 6 x menos 2 entonces
tenemos que restarle 12 y luego tenemos
que restar 2
3 x 4 es 12 12 es cero esto se va menos
2 es menos 2 entonces la función la
función en el punto menos 2 nos da igual
a menos 2 vamos a otro valor vamos a
menos uno menos uno ya sabemos que es el
vértice vamos a ver cuánto nos queda la
función evaluada ahí tendríamos que
hacer tres por uno sería tres menos seis
menos seis menos dos
-2 muy bien 36 es menos tres menos doce
menos cinco entonces en x igual a menos
uno el valor es menos cinco vamos a
poner un par de valores más déjame
ponerlo aquí x igual a cero esto está
fácil de evaluar porque éste se hace
cero éste se hace cero así que
simplemente nos queda menos dos y aquí
se empieza a ver un poquito esta idea de
que menos uno es el vértice de la
parábola porque empezamos a tener
valores simétricos alrededor de menos
uno si estamos en menos 1 y bajamos 1
nos da menos 2 si subimos 1 nos da menos
2 también bueno vamos a seguir le vamos
a poner un valor más voy a poner
1 entonces nos quedaría 3 por 1 al
cuadrado que es 3 + 6 y luego menos 2 -
2 3 669 menos 12 7 así que aquí nos
queda igual a 7 muy bien ya teniendo
estos valores en la tablita vamos a
hacer la gráfica de la función déjame
pintar por aquí
ejes aquí voy a poner un eje vertical y
un eje horizontal
este de aquí va a ser el eje x este va a
ser el eje y vamos a pintar la gráfica
de la función de igual a efe de x vale
entonces como pongo la escala pues a ver
aquí tengo menos 2 menos 101 entonces
voy a poner que es más o menos por ahí
hasta el -1 por acá está el -2 por aquel
uno por acá el dos más o menos y en el
eje tengo que ser un poco más cuidadoso
porque quiero llegar hasta menos cinco y
siete entonces voy a poner más o menos
así la escala
2 3 4 5 6 7 - 1 - 2 - 3 - 4 - 5 muy bien
creo que con esto ya tengo todo para
graficar menos 5 por acá está el 7 el 7
un poco más bonito no todavía más bonito
el 7
ok por acá al menos 2 menos uno el cero
el 1 y el 2
ok entonces voy a pasar estos puntos
aquí a la gráfica vamos a ver qué nos
queda entonces tenemos que poner el
punto menos dos menos dos entonces sería
este de por acá
este es el menos dos coma menos 2
en los dos menos dos muy bien luego
tenemos que poner el -1 5 -1 con al
menos 5 este punto de por acá
vale al menos 15 luego cuando x vale 0
la función vale menos 2 así que tenemos
que poner este puntito el 0 - 2 ahí está
lo de la simetría que te digo alrededor
del menos uno está este y este valor es
como si aquí pusiéramos una línea
vertical y tuviéramos simetría ahorita
se va a ver todavía mejor cuando
complete la parábola deja pongo el
último punto en el 1 vale 7 en 1 vale 7
muy bien así que si el dibujo me queda
más o menos bien lo voy a poner con
blanco lavar la parábola se vería algo
así aquí viene baja llega a este punto
luego comienza a subir y luego sube más
y más
hasta llegar al 7 y de modo similar por
acá también sube
por acá también sube vale entonces esto
que pinta en blanco déjame déjame pongo
algunos puntitos más este de aquí es el
0,2 este de acá es el 27 para que quede
más más bonito entonces ahora sí esto
que pinte en blanco es justo la gráfica
de e igual a efe de x vale y como te
digo o sea tenemos simetría alrededor
del -1 alrededor del vértice que es el
menos uno pero bueno hay que regresar al
problema que es lo importante verdad
todo esto lo hicimos para determinar lo
cual para determinar jaja cuál es el
rango de la función entonces cómo le
hacemos para determinar el rango pues
justo lo que te decía mira del -5 aquí
el valor es menos 5 verdad del -5 hacia
arriba podemos tomar todos los valores
la función toma todos los valores todos
los números reales que están por arriba
de menos 5 sin embargo no hay ningún
punto en la gráfica por debajo de esta
línea es decir la función no toma ningún
valor
ningún valor abajo de menos 5 si esto ya
en el -1 me da menos 5 si voy a hacer la
izquierda subo y voy hacia la derecha
también subo y por lo tanto no puedo
alcanzar valores menores que menos 5
entonces ya déjame escribir eso en color
morado entonces el rango el rango de la
función sería todos los números reales
todos los números reales pero
ideales pero que sean mayores o iguales
a menos cinco de menos cinco para arriba
si se pueden alcanzar de estrictamente
abajo de menos cinco no se pueden
alcanzar